you guys were promoting jackass forever
with the UFC and he's like trying to
pant Dana White at the UFC yeah I
freaking I wasmer did you get him off no
I think he was just kind of
Faking air pants you know trying to be
cool and impress Knoxville and the boys
and they're like what the [__] are you
doing dude and then like the nek boys
were there so all all pump Steve will do
it we're doing like shotgunning happy
Dad I felt so bad because I asked ponus
is wife I was like hey can you film this
real quick ponnie's like what the [__]
are you doing dude like my wife's not a
filmer I think ponnie has had kind of
reached a point that night where he was
over me dude yeah I was sloppy drunk I'm
so glad I'm out of that cuz I was just
pissing people off and disrespecting
situations and just being a coup